- Someone should,
we should check on him
cause it really smell like (censored).
It smells like he,
he pooped in his pants.
(joyful music)
- Guys I just bought this
thing called Liquid Ass.
It's a spray that smells like ass.
It's genius.
So I'm gonna be pranking
my friends with it.
They think they're doing
a video about Amazon.
I'm actually testing our friendship.
- [Fake Producer] Can
I have a clap, Sarah?
- Okay.
(clapping)
- Today we're gonna guess
the price of Amazon products.
- Today we are gonna guess
- (inaudible) I have to go
to the bathroom real quick?
- [Fake Producer] 15 minutes, tops.
- Cool cool cool, yeah yeah.
I've never used Amazon before so.
- Woah! Really?
- Yeah I actually, hold that, sorry.
I have to go, one second I'm sorry.
- Wait, is he okay?
- That's the effect of Prime.
- He has to go to the bathroom, I guess.
He's a toddler.
- That was pretty urgent.
- What did he eat?
- It's fine, I can give him
like five minutes and then,
(laughter)
if not then just recast.
- It might be potty,
it smells like he farted, so I might.
- It smells like
like just straight butt.
- [Eric] Hey sorry about that.
- You all good?
- [Eric] Yeah yeah yeah.
- Cool
No worries, everybody poops.
- Sorry it smells like
- [Man] Ass right here?
- [Eric] Do you guys smell it?
- If you're feeling okay
to do it, we can do it,
but if you're not then
- I'm just so embarrassed
like I think I might have.
I think I might have pooped a little bit.
So I'm really embarrassed.
(laughter)
- Oh my god it still smells, dude.
- Do you smell any? I
don't smell anything.
- [Man Off screen] Smells like ass.
- Should I throw out the underwear?
- Yes!
- Okay wait let me go throw
out the underwear real quick.
- You have them on you?
- [Eric] I still have them on me.
(sighing)
(laughter)
- Hoo boy.
- You good, you clear?
All clear in the underwear?
- [Eric] I just,
I took them off I'm just going
commando YOLO, I don't care.
- Hey, YOLO.
But just don't shit again cause then
you'll be walking around
naked and that would suck.
- I feel so weird now.
- Dude it's fine.
- No.
- You're good.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Has this ever happened to you?
This has never happened to me.
- [Woman] You've never sharted?
- No not as an adult.
You have?
- I definitely have.
(laughter)
- Aw that makes me feel better.
- When I was in Boy Scout camp,
I did shit my pants in a farting contest
and they called me Poop in the Pants Boy.
- I've never shatted before.
- We're adults dude, it's fine.
- Man, your ass, I feel bad for it.
I can only breathe through one
nostril and you fucked me up.
(laughter)
Damn Eric.
- I cannot leave this room
that I pooped my pants.
- Man that scent
definitely left this room.
- Well we gotta do this video
and I've got a meeting at 1:30, so
let's barrel through it,
it's fine.
- Wait can I just say one last thing?
- No, do you want?
- I just wanna say you're
such a good friend.
This was all just a prank.
- No it's not.
What? No!
- This was the fucking video?
You fucker.
- You're preying on the nice people here.
I'm too nice.
- Yeah you didn't say anything!
- I can smell it guys okay,
is that what you wanna hear?
I could smell it the whole time.
- I was just worried about you, man.
I was just like yo he totally
just shat in his pants.
Cause there's no way you
didn't shit in your pants.
- Here's what it smelled like.
Like something was
medically wrong with you.
- But now we know that you
can fart in front of Chris,
you can poop in front of Chris.
- Right in my face.
- And he will just never say anything.
You're my best friend, man.
- Best friends for life.
You could shit your
pants around me any time.
- Stop.
- He got me to admit that
I had sharted as an adult.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
(hinge squeaking)